- I always like to end this show
with a feel good story from the internet.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
A kindergartner from Georgia
has become an unlikely leader
in the fight for workers' rights.
This is six year old Brody.
It's incredible.
A few weeks ago, he took to
social media with an idea
a lot of people can get behind.
- Hey, I'm Brody, and this
is for the government.
And I'm protesting,
and I want three days off of school.
Because, um,
I've been tired of school lately,
and I've been dreaming for three days off.
Two days is not enough from school.
I need three days off.
I need time to just play
and go with Nana and stay home
and do whatever I want.
(crowd cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
- Preach, Brody.
This is not a joke.
Brody started a petition on change.org
that's already garnered
a thousand signatures.
I don't know how there's not
more from all other kids.
Let's get him in here
with his mama Jessica.
What's up y'all?
(crowd cheering)
- Hey, how are you?
- Oh, my gosh. I love your family.
First of all, thank you
for coming on our show!
Brody, a lot of people are behind you.
So what inspired this video?
You just needed a break.
- Yeah, and I think
everybody needs one. And...
- [Kelly] Yes!
- I guess they're getting
tired of school, too.
- You are so cute, dude. You are.
- Thank you.
- Alright. Well, Jessica, is it true
that people want Brody
to run for president?
'Cause I will vote for him.
(Kelly laughing)
- Yes, that is what everybody's saying.
And it's so funny, because
we've always been told
Brody's gonna grow up to be something big,
like the president.
I just didn't expect for nominations
to start rolling in at six years old.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my god. Dream big is what I say.
So Brody, you have some
other campaign promises.
So what are they?
- Give everybody ice
cream sundaes every day
and build the biggest swimming
pool in their backyard.
(crowd cheering)
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
- Oh my gosh.
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all!
Our season long partner
Pilot, pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate inspiring
kids just like you, Brody.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
Considerate an early
campaign contribution.
Bye, y'all! Have a blessed day!
And thank you to all our guests,
Zachary Levi, Lainey Wilson,
Hannah Fry, Jay Leno,
and Novi Brown.
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.